[Music]
you guys know those claw machines
with the toys yeah yeah the toys and and
things that you can
i never caught a single toy with that
they're not designed for you to catch
toys but i also got homies that are
hella good at it really yeah have you
seen the videos on youtube where people
actually catch stuff when they put their
kids inside yeah
there's this denny's we used to go to
and i was for some reason there's always
that one homie that's like
on board and he'll always catch
something really yeah always they know
the technique how many times
every single time we're there no i mean
like how many attempts well the first
quarter first attempt
wow i've never got a single thing i know
what i'm really good at the [ __ ]
thing at the fair when you toss
toss something you have to ricochet and
then put it put into a basket we have to
bounce off the wall has to get into that
yeah you're good at that very good you
need long arms
because you have to get below and then
ricochet high enough like that i would
get it every [ __ ] time
have you ever tried shooting into the
oval rims
because at the fair there they have
basketball right but they purposely [ __ ]
you so it's like a little oval rim yeah
so it has to be like perfectly like
swish
every time it's always bouncing like all
kinds of weird places
well that was this guy how many times do
you think that you'll give yourself to
attempt at like
getting something from a claw machine
like how many two times
a dollar's worth just once yeah because
i suck a quarter's worth twice
because once the first time i could see
where it's off yeah second time
i get after two i'm like this [ __ ] sucks
yeah i give myself two
and if i'm really competitive that day
like i really feel like not [ __ ] this
i'm gonna get it i'll go three times
yeah
then i go one and then when no one's
looking i [ __ ] shake the [ __ ]
shake the toy out of the hole there's
this guy there's this guy
in japan of course he spent his [ __ ]
13 years trying to get that one that
shit's
sick in japan though because the prizes
that are in those claw machines
it's like an ipad and [ __ ] yeah there's
like appliances
and a microwave [ __ ] a rice cooker
yeah so how many times do you think this
guy won
well if it's japan he's it's three years
worth yeah japanese dedication
spent his paycheck ah 200 times
he tried for 200 times and after 200
times
which i'm like were you keeping track or
is it whatever it is
no he actually called the police and he
said this game is unwinnable this is
some [ __ ]
come over here and arrest this machine
what if the police does it once and gets
it
they're like oh you're just a stupid
takashi
once the police got there they asked the
arcade operator
to demonstrate that the machine actually
worked and like it could be beat
guess how many times the machine
operator tried once no
200 half a time he didn't even try two
two times no closer to what bart was
saying 300 300 times
so he actually got it after 300 times he
failed 300 times in a row
and at that point they stood there
[ __ ] 300 times
oh well maybe because they were like we
need to see if this is rigged it's
covered that's why they have nothing
better to do
i know so after 300 times that's
they take gaming serious out there
that's when the the arcade operator
went like open the machine and move some
of the prizes into more favor
favorable locations and finally that's
when they were able to
pick one up he did it for 300 times yeah
but he had to adjust everything like
that in order for it to happen so it's
still [ __ ] cheating yeah he can just
dust it back after the police
officer goes away probably but the fact
that the police were
like actually patient enough to be there
and wait
another whole 300 times it's so crazy
okay
no okay no like how many hours is that
and it takes a while too because it has
to return to the start position and then
and then it dangles yeah and you have to
put the money back in
and it's like yeah why are you too good
at that
so the original man who was attempting
at it he
ended up tweeting out a picture and it
said i couldn't win
at all so now the police are here uh the
police are investigating the staff
member who still hasn't won yet
and then um and then later on he updated
the fact that
the man the operator ended up moving
things around so then it could be
winnable
but that just went viral and the the
company themselves that
created that machine they ended up
saying uh as a whole
crane games that's what they call it
crane games are
meant to be enjoyed as a way for
customers to try their skill in luck and
playing knowing that they want that when
they put money in
a price may not necessarily come out of
course we strive to have
our staff be aware of customer
situations so if something seems off you
are welcome to call them over and have
them assist you a little bit this is a
fundamental operation of our company
that's pretty much the conclusion they
didn't
they basically said [ __ ] you and you had
to call up you had to call up for backup
and then what what's the toy that
they're trying to get a big [ __ ]
chick look at that it's like a little
bird it's a baby
i've been trying to get this baby
chicken i was like a little girl
oh oh a little pervert it's like a baby
sailor moon
oh dude you know that they're closing
the sega arcades in
akihabara oh really yeah why you know
those
seven story eight-story arcades we went
to yeah some of them are getting close
because the kovid they just run out of
money or whatever i don't know
it [ __ ] sucks yeah two floors of that
like
it's just crane games when i went last
time oh no man
damn i missed japan man oh yeah i'm
supposed to go
you are supposed to or you were supposed
to i was supposed to
but even if i go i can't even see my
mother because like corona
when will this be over so we can hurry
up and travel as soon as they say
that it's safe to travel i'm gonna
assume that corona is a thing of the
past and it just disappeared
i'm gonna act like it never happened all
right i cannot wait man
the first first place i'm going
korea
no you have to quarantine there for two
weeks though are you supposed to get
tested before some [ __ ] oh right now for
hawaii it's
um just today i think they announced
that if you have a 72-hour
test okay that's new then because my
parents owned property there and they
were like we can't even go
look at like visit because yeah and they
they're trying to rent it out again and
like they're having a tough time so they
need to go over there but then they have
to quarantine for two weeks
before they can like leave to go look at
their property wow
that's intense i cannot wait i was
supposed to go to vietnam
and then that [ __ ] got i'm still waiting
for my [ __ ] refund for my ticket
it's been over six months now wait
you're still waiting on that it's just
200 40 200 are you gonna get a refund or
can you just book another flight
uh anything so you you're just waiting
for anything right now so they haven't
been able to respond back they keep on
emailing me saying they're working on it
so
at least that's it for six months did
the business go under
who knows but they're still continuing
to email me saying like hey we're still
working on it right now so
we got two we got so the first time i
booked it we got that refund back
immediately right but then uh mariel
wanted to risk it and say like hey it's
probably
let's do it again i did it again and
that was like a 4 200
ticket for both of us and then i'm still
waiting on that [ __ ] man
because your boy has to fight business
class because oh yeah i got those back
problems
being almost like a 20 yeah and it's not
direct
yeah so well yeah we're supposed to go
to korea stop off in korea and then go
to vietnam and we're supposed to be
there for three weeks
so i'm supposed to be in like the cuts
like i'm talking about village [ __ ]
but vietnam is really amazing yeah that
sucks
you should try riding scooters there you
might crash but thank you dude
but yeah so the fact that
everyone on twitter they were just like
obviously everyone knows that the crane
games are a scam
uh they said everyone knows the crane
strength is proportional to how much
money has been put in
one person ended up commenting and
another one said
the game is just putting your coin in
the slot
once you win a prize from the crane game
though you never have to do it again you
realize how stupid it is like once i got
like little plush toy from it i'm like
that's it and i've never played it since
why are you surprised don't you
literally see it as you're grabbing it
no when you get it you should feel like
like a sort of accomplishment yeah i was
reading a book about how like
we find happiness more in the
anticipation of something than we do in
actually getting that's really what it
is for the crane game because once i got
that stupid doll thing i was like
i wasted a bunch you put it back inside
i wouldn't bet this is dumb and i put my
arm back in i went
yeah i got stuck keep it sometimes i do
enjoy the flight more than the place
yeah like where so we don't go there
especially if it's business bus
because it it's like oh i know i never
want the flight to end yeah i'm like can
i can we just like circle the planet
like this is so nice
damn that sucks i'm never like that dude
i'm trying to get there i'm gonna have
some [ __ ] fun are you nuts
yeah i take it back all the destinations
been pretty sick yeah but i also love
going there too so but so after you come
back though you're kind of like um
but the thing is like when you grow up
like really poor when you're in a
business class seat i'm trying to stay
awake the whole time
i want everybody i'm like you stay awake
you're just like oh my god i'm laying
down on the airplane this is so sick
because last time we came back
uh with those business class tickets i
remember from japan
i remember just [ __ ] trying to stay
awake but i fell asleep through every
[ __ ] meal and i woke up in the states
i was like
[ __ ] man the food was good you fell
asleep through every meal
because it was so comfortable you know
you could ask them once you wake up
i think they did try to wake me up but i
just wasn't having it david what's this
yeah we're we're trash uh people and
steve's such white trash like he
found out that they give you like free
alcohol in the that mini bar you know
and they had a johnny walker blue or the
or black the one that's expensive
i can't remember which one it is yeah
and so he like drank a full bottle of it
because he kept going back and getting
shots just because it was like
so expensive and it was free that was so
chinese is unreal dude
it's [ __ ] unreal one of the one of
the tickets uh
place that i had i remember which
airline it was but in the back they just
had a nice standing bar so you could
stand up and talk to everybody
is that virgin yeah that's nice i can't
remember it was not
i think qantas has that honda's has a
tool yeah but there's like a little bar
like a half star stretch out your legs
they have like seats like little dining
seats that you can eat like it's a
restaurant yeah it's so nice
remember david i can't remember it
remember
i saw it on qantas so maybe maybe it was
something like that i can't remember at
all oh i miss traveling i miss just
me too being outside of the usa what
other countries are open like they're
done with it well croatia was
allowing u.s citizens but then they
blocked us korea is beautiful
yes right now you could go to london but
you have to no didn't they just have
like a like a
yeah an outbreak like recently they're
still letting americans in
turkey will go flying yeah the turkey is
letting us in there's like a few
countries that is letting us in
my mom send me videos from taiwan and
everyone's just chilling now
it's regular like people are the
department stores it's packed oh your
mom's been in taiwan this whole time
it's been in taiwan the whole time and
every time she wants to come back
it's like america keeps getting worse
she's like i'm going to stay out here
but she's remember florida's open
she's been the flight 10 months it is
disneyland out there is open too
it's disney world yeah yeah on my bed
disney world is open
where did you guys go to disneyland oh
downtown disney because that's not open
we try to go in but the line is long
no the line is [ __ ] long as [ __ ]
though lines over what
you're doing yeah they take your
temperature
temperature [ __ ] metal detectors yeah
so many people in at a time
yeah right before the pandemic kit i
bought this like three day package thing
and we only used one
so i'm like what happened to my other
two i think they they freeze it and i
think you can use it we have season
passes
they froze ours it's frozen like a
popsicle yes it's so delicious
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you